TUCKER, THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: AT LEAST HE IS
COOKING YOU DINNER!
>> Sean: I’M GLAD.
BUSY NIGHT TONIGHT.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
THE LEFT IS GETTING VERY
DESPERATE AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TRYING TO
DISSOLVE THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION WITH A NEW LAWSUIT.
IT REALLY?
JUST 89 DAYS BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
SOUNDS LIKE WEIRD TIMING TO ME.
SO IS THE STATE OF NEW YORK
USING TAXPAYER MONEY TO
INTERFERE IN THE 2020 ELECTION?
WHY NOW?
WE’LL EXPLAIN.
I THINK THERE ARE OTHER
PRIORITIES THE STATE SHOULD BE
CONCERNED ABOUT, LIKE SAFETY AND
THE LIVES OF CITIZENS.
WE’LL INVESTIGATE THAT.
ALSO, THIS MADNESS ALONG WITH
THE LEFT’S CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
THEIR SLANDER RATCHETING UP
BECAUSE DEMOCRATS HAVE NOTHING
POSITIVE TO RUN ON, AND THIS IS
NOW A FACT.
JOE BIDEN IS A DISASTER.
HE LOOKS WELL, HE LOOKS
EXTREMELY WEAK, EVEN FROM
HIS BASEMENT BUNKER, WITH THE
LIGHTEST POSSIBLE SCHEDULE OF
ANY PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE IN
HISTORY.
HE IS STRUGGLING AND STRUGGLING
BIG TIME.
WHAT A WHOPPER A DAY, WE WILL
CALL IT, TODAY.
HE’S REALLY NOT EVEN
CAMPAIGNING.
HE’S POKING HIS HEAD UP FOR AN
HOUR OR TWO AND YET HE CANNOT
HOLD IT TOGETHER.
SO FAR THIS WEEK HAS BEEN AN
UNMITIGATED DISASTER.
IT STARTED WHEN BIDEN HAD A
WEIRD, STRANGE, EMBARRASSING
PUBLIC BREAKDOWN WHILE TOUTING
HIS COGNITIVE FITNESS.
SEE IF YOU CAN UNDERSTAND THIS
AND PAY VERY CLOSE ATTENTION TO
THE WORDS "FITNESS" AT THE END
OF THIS.
>> PLEASE CLARIFY, SPECIFICALLY,
HAVE YOU TAKEN A COGNITIVE --
>> NO, I HAVEN’T TAKEN A TEST.
WHY THE HILL WOULD I TAKE A TEST
TEST?
COME ON, MAN.
THAT IS LIKE SAYING YOU BEFORE
YOU TAKE THE PROGRAM YOU TAKE A
TEST WHETHER YOU’RE TAKING
COCAINE OR NOT?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
ARE YOU A JUNKIE?
>> WHAT DO YOU SAY TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO BRAGS ABOUT
HIS TEST AND MAKES YOUR EFFORTS
AND ISSUE FOR THE VOTERS.
>> IF HE CAN’T FIGURE OUT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN AN ELEPHANT
AND A LINE, I DON’T KNOW WHAT
THE HELL HE’S TALKING ABOUT.
DID YOU WATCH THAT?
COME ON, MAN.
I KNOW YOU’RE TRYING TO GOAD ME
BUT I AM SO FORWARD-LOOKING TO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO SIT WITH
THE PRESIDENT OR STAND WITH THE
PRESIDENT AND DEBATE.
IT THERE’S GOING TO BE PLENTY OF
TIME FEARED BY THE WAY, AS I JOK
WITH HIM -- I SHOULDN’T SAY IT.
I’M GOING TO SAY SOMETHING I
PROBABLY SHOULDN’T SAY.
ANYWAY, I AM VERY WILLING TO LET
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC COULD JUDGE
MY PHYSICAL AND MENTAL -- MY
PHYSICAL AS WELL AS MY MENTAL
FITNESS, AND TWO, YOU KNOW, MAKE
A JUDGMENT ABOUT WHO I AM.
>> Sean: COME ON, MAN!
WE NEED BUMPER STICKERS AND
T-SHIRTS.
LET’S SEE, DID YOU GET TESTED
FOR COCAINE?
ARE YOU A JUNKIE?
COME ON, MAN.
HE LOSES HIS TRAIN OF THOUGHT
THREE TIMES IN A MINUTE.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT THE HELL HE’S
TALKING ABOUT.
AN ELEPHANT AND A LION?
YOU KNOW, WHAT DOES HE MEAN HERE
HERE?
THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING OF
HIS BAD WEEK.
WHY IS HE HAVING SUCH A HARD
TIME SAYING I LOOK FORWARD TO
THE FITNESS.
IF HE REALLY MEANS THAT, WE CAN
HAVE THE EXTRA DEBATE THAT
DONALD TRUMP HAS CALLED FOR
BEFORE ANYONE VOTES BEFORE EARLY
VOTING STARTS.
THAT IS FAIR FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
IT LET THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DECIDE.
JOE SAYS HE’S LOOKING FORWARD TO
IT.
OKAY, GAME ON, JOE.
DO IT BEFORE A SINGLE VOTE IS
CAST.
CAN’T SAY THE WORD FITNESS AND
BY THE WAY, A SHORT TIME AGO, AS
A MATTER OF FACT, HE SAID OF
COURSE I HAD A COGNITIVE EXAM.
I AM TESTED CONSTANTLY.
OKAY, WHEN HE’S OUT OF THE
BASEMENT BUNKER, HE DOESN’T KNOW
SOMETIMES WHAT CITY HE IS IN, HE
DOESN’T KNOW WHAT OFFICE HE IS
RUNNING FOR AT TIMES.
HE DOESN’T REMEMBER OR DOESN’T
SEEM TO REMEMBER THAT WE ARE
ENDOWED BY OUR, THE THING, YOU
KNOW, THE DASH THE THING.
JOE, THE ANSWER IS GOD.
THE CREATOR OF EVERYTHING.
IF YOU FORGET, GIVE ME A CALL,
I’LL HELP YOU OUT IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE DEBATE, WE CAN CHEAT,
NOBODY WILL KNOW.
HE CAN’T TELL HIS WIFE FROM HIS
SISTER AT ONE TIME, SO WE’LL USE
HIS WORDS.
COME ON, MAN.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT THE HELL HE’S
SAYING.
WHAT’S GOING ON HERE?
DEMOCRATS REFUSE TO TALK ABOUT
IT IN PUBLIC.
THE MOB AND THE MEDIA, THEY’RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT IT IN PUBLIC.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU, I KNOW FOR A
FACT IN PRIVATE, THEY ARE
TELLING ME AND MANY OTHER PEOPLE
THEY KNOW IT IS A SERIOUS
PROBLEM.
THEY CAN’T PUT THEIR HEAD IN THE
SAND FOREVER, LIKE AN OSTRICH.
I LIKE IT OR NOT, BIDEN’S
COGNITIVE ABILITIES ARE
EXTREMELY TROUBLING AND THEY
WILL BE ON THE BALLOT.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING, FRANKLY, IS
JUST BIZARRE.
IT’S NOT NORMAL.
THAT’S ALL I KNOW.
I LOOK AT A FRAIL GUY WHO IF HE
EVER HAD A SLOW PITCH SEEMS TO
BE GONE.
WE WITNESSED TODAY AND OF THE
DISASTER FOR BIDEN AFTER A
VIRTUAL EVENT WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF BLACK
JOURNALISTS, NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION JOURNALISTS, BIDEN
SUGGESTED THAT AFRICAN-AMERICANS
ARE ALL THE SAME.
AT WOW.
FIRST WE HEARD YOU AIN’T BLACK,
NOW THIS?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> UNLIKE THE AFRICAN-AMERICAN
COMMUNITY WITH NOTABLE
EXCEPTIONS, THE LATINO COMMUNITY
IS INCREDIBLY DIVERSE COMMUNITY
COMMUNITY.
WITH INCREDIBLY DIFFERENT
ATTITUDES ABOUT DIFFERENT
THINGS.
>> Sean: OKAY, WE’LL LET YOU
DECIDE.
PRETTY MUCH A TERRIBLE THING TO
SAY.
JUDGMENT, BROAD SWEEPING
GENERALIZATION.
EARLIER, PRESIDENT TRUMP
RESPONDED, CALLING HIS REMARKS A
GREAT INSULT TO THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> JOE BIDEN THIS MORNING
TOTALLY DISPARAGED AND INSULTED
THE BLACK COMMUNITY.
WHAT HE SAID IS INCREDIBLE AND I
DON’T KNOW WHAT’S GOING ON WITH
HIM, BUT IT WAS A VERY INSULTING
STATEMENT HE MADE.
IT WAS A GREAT INSULT OF THE
BLACK COMMUNITY.
>> Sean: FOR THE RECORD IT WAS
DONALD TRUMP WHO PUT CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM, HE’S THE ONE
WHO DID IT, NOT BARACK, NOT JOE.
POLICE REFORM, THAT IS TRUMP,
NOT BARACK, NOT JOE.
FUNDING FOR THE LARGEST AMOUNT
OF MONEY AND THE LONGEST
COMMITMENT OF TIME, HISTORICALLY
BLACK COLLEGES, THAT WAS
DONALD TRUMP HERE THAT WAS NOT
BARACK AND IT WASN’T JOE.
BY THE WAY, RECORD AFTER RECORD
AFTER RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT
FOR EVERY DEMOGRAPHIC IN THIS
COUNTRY, INCLUDING
AFRICAN-AMERICANS AND
HISPANIC-AMERICANS.
YEAH, THAT WAS DONALD TRUMP.
BIDEN AND OBAMA GAVE US
13 MILLION MORE AMERICANS ON
FOOD STAMPS AFTER EIGHT YEARS,
AND 8 BILLION MORE IN POVERTY,
AND THE LOWEST PARTICIPATION
RATE AND 70s.
LOWEST RECOVERY SINCE THE
’40s.
THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT AND BY
THE WAY, CAN YOU IMAGINE THE
HYSTERIA ON THE LEFT IF IT WAS
TRUMP WHO MADE THOSE HORRIBLE
REMARKS?
YOU KEEP IN MIND, THIS IS NOT AN
ISOLATED INCIDENT FOR THE EVER
FORGETFUL AND CORRUPT JOE.
HIS TRACK RECORD ON RACE IS
ATROCIOUS.
HIS CLOSE PERSONAL MENTOR, AS HE
SAYS, THE PERSON HE PRAYS WAS,
YEAH, THE FORMER KLANSMAN ROBERT
KKK BIRD.
THE GUY WHO FILIBUSTERED THE
CIVIL RIGHTS ACT OF ’64, POST OF
THE VOTING RIGHTS ACT UP ’65.
LYNDON JOHNSON RELIED ON 80%
REPUBLICANS IN THE HOUSE AND
SENATE TO PASS THAT.
NOT A LOT OF DEMOCRATS.
HE WASN’T THERE WHEN HISTORY
MATTERED.
IMAGINE IF DONALD TRUMP PRAISED
A FORMER CLAN LEADER WHO IN FACT
FILIBUSTERED THE CIVIL RIGHTS
ACT.
IN THE 70s, BIDEN ACTIVELY
WORKING WITH THE SEGREGATIONIST.
WHY?
TO SLOW SCHOOL INTEGRATION.
LET’S GO TO NBC NEWS, SHALL WE?
HE LED THE CHARGE ON AN ISSUE
THAT KEPT BLACK STUDENTS AWAY
FROM THE CLASSROOMS OF WHITE
STUDENTS.
ACCORDING TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST"," BIDEN
SPOKE OUT REPEATEDLY AND
FORCEFULLY AGAINST SENDING WHITE
CHILDREN TO MAJORITY BLACK
SCHOOLS AND BLACK CHILDREN TO
MAJORITY WHITE SCHOOLS.
1977, BIDEN WORRIED THAT HIS
CHILDREN WOULD GROW UP IN A
RACIAL JUNGLE.
A FEW YEARS LATER, BIDEN LIED
ABOUT MARCHING IN THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT.
HE ALSO LIED ABOUT ENDORSEMENTS
FROM THE NAACP IN 1993.
HE’S THE GUY THAT REFERRED TO
INNER-CITY YOUTH AS PREDATORS ON
OUR STREETS.
2006, HE’S THE GUY THAT TOLD THE
CROWD, YOU HAVE TO HAVE A SLIGHT
INDIAN ACCENT TO WORK AT A
7-ELEVEN OR A DUNKIN’ DONUTS.
I’M NOT KIDDING.
2006, HE BRAGGED THAT HIS STATE
WAS A STATE.
2007, HE’S THE GUY WHO SAID, KEY
WORD HERE THIS IS THE FIRST
MAINSTREAM AFRICAN-AMERICAN WHO
IS ARTICULATE AND BRIGHT AND
CLEAN.
THAT STORYBOOK, MAN.
COME ON, MAN.
MAN COMES UP A LOT WITH THIS
GUY.
ANYWAY LAST YEAR HE SAID POOR
KIDS COULD BE JUST AS BRIGHT AS
WHITE KIDS.
RECENTLY HE SAID "YOU AIN’T
BLACK IF YOU SUPPORT
DONALD TRUMP."
THEN HE SAID, HE WILL PUT Y’ALL
BACK IN CHAINS.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT, BIDEN’S
TRACK RECORD ON RACE IS NOTHING
SHORT OF A DISGRACE AND IMAGINE
IF DONALD TRUMP HAD SET ALL
THESE THINGS.
>> POOR KIDS ARE JUST AS BRIGHT
AND JUST AS TALENTED AS WHITE
KIDS.
>> YOU CANNOT GO TO A 7-ELEVEN
OR A DUNKIN’ DONUTS UNLESS YOU
HAVE A SLIGHT INDIAN ACCENT.
I’M NOT JOKING.
DESPICABLE KIND OF CHANCE WILL
THE NORTHEASTERN LIBERAL LIKE
JOE BIDEN STAND IN THE SOUTH?
>> BETTER THAN ANYBODY ELSE.
YOU DON’T KNOW MY STATE.
MY STATE WAS A STATE, THE EIGHTH
LARGEST BLACK POPULATION IN THE
COUNTRY.
SPEAK OF THE FIRST SORT OF
MAINSTREAM AFRICAN-AMERICAN WHO
ARTICULATE AND BRIGHT AND CLEAN
AND A NICE-LOOKING GUY.
I MEAN, THAT IS STORYBOOK.
TO SPEAK AT THEIR GOING TO PUT
Y’ALL BACK IN CHAINS.
>> IT’S A LONG WAY UNTIL
NOVEMBER, WE’VE GOT MORE
QUESTIONS.
>> YOU HAVE MORE QUESTIONS.
IF YOU HAVE A PROBLEM FIGURING
OUT IF YOU ARE FOR ME OR FOR
TRUMP, THEN YOU AIN’T BLACK.
>> Sean: OKAY, IF BIDEN WERE A
REPUBLICAN OR DONALD TRUMP, HE
WOULD BE RIPPED TO SHREDS BY HIS
OWN DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THE
MEDIA MOB.
THE MEDIA DIVIDES RICH VERSUS
POOR, OLD VERSUS YOUNG, BLACK
VERSUS WHITE.
I PLAYED THAT HISTORY
REPEATEDLY, AND BY THE WAY,
BIDEN STATEMENT TODAY, HIS
STATEMENT ABOUT
AFRICAN-AMERICANS WASN’T THE
ONLY PUZZLING MOMENT FROM THE
EVENT.
IN ONE MOMENT, HE ACTUALLY
CHANGED HIS POSITION ON THE
FILIBUSTER ALMOST MIDSENTENCE.
THIS IS THE SAME EXACT VIRTUAL
HEARING.
IT’S NOT LIKE, WELL, I’VE BEEN
TESTED, I’M CONSTANTLY TESTED,
I’VE NEVER BEEN TESTED, HOW DARE
YOU ASK ME IF I’M TESTED?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT I SAID AS IF, IN FACT,
THEY ARE AS OBSTREPEROUS AS
SUGGESTED, WE HAVE TO GET RID OF
THE FILIBUSTER.
BUT THE FILIBUSTER HAS ALSO
SAVED A LOT OF BAD THINGS FROM
HAPPENING, TOO.
>> SO, YOU’RE OPEN?
>> OH, YEAH, I’M SORRY.
I’M ON RECORD AS SAYING THAT.
IF THE REPUBLICANS, IF THERE IS
NO WAY TO MOVE OTHER THAN
GETTING RID OF THE FILIBUSTER,
THAT IS WHAT WE’LL DO.
>> Sean: BIDEN EARLIER TODAY
MADE COMMENTS ABOUT THE
DIVERSITY OF AFRICAN AND LATINO
COMMUNITIES.
I WANT TO CLARIFY, IN NO WAY DID
I MEAN TO SUGGEST THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN COMMUNITY IS A
MONOLITH.
NOT BY IDENTITY, NOT ON ISSUES
AT ALL.
THROUGHOUT MY CAREER.
WE ARE LAYING OUT YOUR CAREER.
I’VE WITNESSED A DIVERSITY OF
THOUGHT, BACKGROUND, SENTIMENT.
YEAH, OKAY.
AS YOU CAN SEE, THAT JUST CAME
OUT.
HE JUST TWEETED THAT OUT.
IT’S NOT JUST BECAUSE OF HIS
INABILITY TO COMMUNICATE CLEARLY
BUT ALSO, HE IS STRUGGLING TO
SHORE UP HIS RADICAL SOCIALIST
BASE.
NOW BY THE WAY, IN ORDER TO MAKE
THEM HAPPY, HE IS RUNNING
THE MOST PROGRESSIVE PLATFORM
THAT’S EVER EXISTED IN HISTORY.
HE HAS VOWED TO HALT ALL
BORDER WALL CONSTRUCTION IF
PRESIDENT, HE HAS VOWED TO GRANT
AMNESTY TO ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
IN OTHER WORDS WHAT WOULD BECOME
THE UNITED CENTURY STATES OF
AMERICA.
HE ALSO SAID ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
SHOULD RECEIVE SUBSIDIZED
HEALTH CARE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SHOULD UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS ALSO BE ABLE TO GET
SUBSIDIZED HEALTH CARE?
>> IF THEY ARE WORKING IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AND
THEY ARE PAYING TAXES, THEY
SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE.
THEY SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO WHAT
EVERYBODY ELSE HAS ACCESS TO.
>> AND UNDOCUMENTED WORKER?
>> NOW, IT DEPENDS.
NOT ALL UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS ARE
WORKING.
YOU SAY EVERY UNDOCUMENTED
WORKER.
>> Sean: HE WANT FROM US
AMNESTY, JUST ADDED TO THE LIST,
GOVERNMENT SUBSIDY, HIS $92
APPEASEMENT FOR THE GREEN NEW
DEAL IS OFFERING TO SPEND
TRILLIONS ON AOC’S PLAN, WHICH
IS MADNESS.
DOUBLING DOWN ON STUPID.
OBAMACARE, SOME VERSION OF
MEDICARE FOR ALL.
FREE HOUSING, FREE HIGHER
EDUCATION, FREE HEALTHY FOOD BY
THE GOVERNMENT GUARANTEED, FREE
CHILD CARE, FREE FAMILY LEAVE,
FREE VACATION, FREE, FREE, FREE,
EVERYTHING’S FREE.
ALL YOUR NEEDS WILL BE TAKEN
CARE OF, CRADLE TO GRAVE, WOMB
TO TOMB.
ALL YOUR WORRIES ELIMINATED IN A
MAGICAL SOCIALIST UTOPIA.
THE ONLY PROBLEM IS THESE
PROBLEMS ARE COMPLETELY UNFOR
FILLABLE.
THEY ARE FALSE PROMISES.
THE MATH DOESN’T ADD UP, NOT
EVEN ON JOE’S OLD FASHION
ABACUS.
IF THIS RADICAL AGENDA IS EVER
IMPLEMENTED, YOUR FRIENDS AND
YOUR FREEDOM, FOR RANSOM OF THE
FRIENDS THAT LOVE FREEDOM, IT’S
GOING TO BE STRIPPED AWAY.
YOUR WEALTH WILL BE CONFISCATED.
YOUR BUSINESSES WILL BE
DESTROYED.
AMERICA AS WE KNOW IT, THAT IS
FREEDOM AND LIBERTY AND GUESS
WHAT?
CAPITALISM WILL BE GONE.
THEY ARE STATUS, THESE ARE
SOCIALIST POLICIES, AND THEY
WILL FAIL.
IT’S BEEN TRIED, IT’S FAILED TO
MANY TIMES TO COUNT.
AND THAT IS WHAT IS ON THE